hi welcome to another episode of my
let's play and it's time to open this
thing now that's a very hard thing to do
you'll have to click on this button and
it opens good how much money am I asking
for this thing only one euro ridiculous
blasphemy we need to be about one-sixth
what no one-third 1,700 and this can be
one five ten nice so you can see that
that scenery and all that actually
really helps to get the excitement
rating up now this is going to be the
what did I call my earlier junior
coaster again I totally forgot the name
but anyway this thing is going to be
caught the the it's gonna be sexy no
wait I have a better idea
this is Ricky Martin the ride oh that's
a very good idea actually I'm going to
call all of my rollercoasters something
the ride Oh sometimes I'm just too
genius for myself okay so it needs trees
and stuff but I'll add that later okay
so basically this is what we have it's
not too much yet however the main
walkway kind of ends over here by the
way we need benches and nope I am NOT
adding handyman because they're not
because they're not really needed
because nobody's really vomited all my
things yet and I don't really need one
of these mechanics because nothing's
broken down that's how it works
sometimes life can be very easy like
that what we need is a scrambled eggs
because a forest fontys without a
scrambled eggs isn't a forest frontiers
for the very reason that you get it from
the beginning of the game so that's what
everybody gets it okay so why do I place
this wing I kind of want to go over here
and like more over here so probably want
to play something here too okay good I
might want to extend the path over here
as well but nope I'm not going to do
that main walkway is just going to be
around that rollercoaster
and no don't do that bad cue it's going
to be the scrambled eggs also known as
what minutes to fromage where's my F ah
there we go I'm not that bad a blind
typing oh nice however needs more hedges
sorry hatches
okay so place those there we go hey stop
that
how am I is this bad at using a mouse oh
hey that doesn't look too good well that
looks a bit better what's acceptable and
we put an elephant over here wait no
that's two fountains you're gonna put a
giraffe over here that makes no sense
come on rollercoaster go three khans
you'll have scenery that makes sense
like at least at some scenery that
actually is is logical and this thing is
ugly I think there's no other no other
choice but to just play some of these
furs okay first it is well they're nice
too in their own right
and some of these other phones because
there there's so these not ferns there
furs and some of these really we call
these things some of these nameless oh
this is just terrific
Wow voila Co second three I mean roller
coaster cone
I mean I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm taupe I
will never make that mistake again
I'm very sorry do I really need that yes
I need that in my life
good okay now the guests might be very
sick and all that but I don't care they
need to be sick no I'm going to build a
toilet somewhere I'm sorry it's not
called a toilet it's called a bathroom
so I'm going to build this I'm going to
build I'm going to build this bathroom
sorry bathroom somewhere I don't have
any room and then how I don't have any
bathroom this might in the middle of the
helix yeah definitely
I almost have that feeling again that I
should build something in the middle of
this helix simply because you just need
to build something in the middle for
helix but I'm not going to do that I'll
just build the bathroom over here it's a
decent place and oh I'm sorry bathroom
and we need more Chinese Cedars because
those things are beautiful
actually no that doesn't make sense over
there let me get this this what's it
called the birch we have a silver birch
we don't have any other birches but we
have a silver one so that works with
some furrows around it if I call these
things ferns one more time I swear I'm
gonna take a shot of vodka okay and a
bit of ground just rubbery because we
always need that
I'll just hear those guests screaming in
agony over the painful Ricky Martin the
ride going over these hills while Viva
Viva la Vida what Viva Viva la Vida la
vida loca sometimes speaking is so hard
especially Spanish because I don't know
any Spanish except for me casa su casa
and I knew beer at some time at some
point in time but I don't need that
anymore
so also has my research doing see we
don't need log flumes nobody likes log
flumes just and we don't need shops and
stores either we need gentle we don't
need any gentle eyes either
we just want rollercoasters and thrill
rides that that's what we are here from
it's called roller coaster tycoon not
gentle right tycoon looks pretty decent
now I want a pirate ship hey that was
about it no way that was a very bad idea
I shouldn't just say hey I'm like this
and then just randomly place it that
doesn't work I should actually kind of
plan it like that over there this might
be a good location for it yeah that
works and now it's in front of trees so
removed the trees and I'll place them
later on because I'm stupid like that
but for now I don't want them that's
kind of a bit too symmetrical but it's
not like I really care about that but
it's just something that I found we're
going to open the swinging ship however
it's gonna be called the ER they are
horror a swing swing swing your ship
what oh we stopped wait six what no no
aah I don't I shouldn't use this
pop-filter because I can't see my it
looks good I'm gonna do front oh wait
yeah of course I shouldn't use this
pop-filter because I can't see my
keyboard and I suck at typing but that's
a story for another time
what we need is a hedge because this is
a thrill ride and thrill rides always
need a Doric hedge I don't know why that
that's just I'm not even kidding that to
something that's in my mind like thrill
rides equals die courage and not thrill
rides or rollercoasters equals and light
edge I have no clue why sometimes my
brain just does weird stuff pretty nice
need some more trees up in here though
and of course another silver birch is I
like that tree more firs over here the
trees in here actually probably better
than this reason roller coaster going 3
ok so we got this little thing and place
it oh it's too big we need a smaller
thing oh this thing is small enough so
we get that thing good oh wait I still
want to change the colors on this thing
as well as on the omelette du fromage
because I don't know why but for some
reason I just don't like the colors if
they're not the standard colors though
omelette du fromage looks pretty decent
like that it shouldn't be purple
Purple's already used in this park
there's already a bit of green in the
park but I think green looks good yeah
green looks pretty cool okay so what
else do we want hmm
what we need is an area like a food
court very popular term note this down
food courts you need a food court and
you also need to call it a food court if
you don't you're not a very experienced
and pro roller coaster tycoon player
where's my food courts gonna be I have
no clue damn it it's gonna be here yes
drinks tall and burger bar for all you
Americans out there and now you might
think hey that foot cord is in the
middle of nowhere
of wait there we go beautiful food wait
that's the long way around I went over
there like that nice and this is just
going to be the dream store come on BEC
space thank you and this is going to be
the burger bar so all the fat Americans
can visit my park as well sorry so all
the fat Americans can visit my park as
well okay sorry and I know offense I
haven't I haven't even used too many
fences over here so a little mesh fence
always goes especially around these two
things I don't know why but I just like
I just always like that like I said
sometimes my brain does weird stuff now
this of course goes with those trees and
we'll use these little flowery bushes
which is called give me the name Bush
very cool you're either with us or
you're against us Bush man I feel like
this little place needs some fencing as
well however it needs different fencing
no not that fencing that fence is to
dance in this fence
I like this fence however the food court
no the food court is pretty good as it
is now no need to change that however I
don't really like the fact that it has
the same path as that other area this
should be better that is definitely
better I don't want to use the same path
over there with that symmetrical system
that it's in okay so let's see some
benches because you always need benches
around your food court and litter bins
and of course people aren't really
eating there yet and oops I still need
to turn the price up of the your horror
swinging you ship and Alma let me
fromage and that's good
what's the next thing going to be oh yes
the steel roller coaster we're gonna get
the steel roller coaster we're gonna
build some epic [ __ ] okay looks pretty
cool
how much time do I have left plenty of
time so it's time for one more
attraction hey I haven't even placed a
spiral slide yet that's a crime in my
books so spiral slide is gonna go I
don't know actually
where's the spiral slide going to go if
I really want to place a roller coaster
I'd probably like to place it over here
or something so the spiral slide should
probably go in this area that I still
have okay nice
I probably shouldn't change the colors
on it because colors like this are
pretty cool and there we go and we need
one of one mechanic because something's
broken down I didn't even see what broke
down and we need some handyman because I
can see puke oh that it's dirty bad boy
now this is gonna be the slide okay cool
beautiful name and I don't know what
kind of trees I want over here I haven't
used this tree yet however if I do want
to use that I'd probably want to use
that over here
well I like that just kind of mixing
different trees in one Park always ends
up pretty nice as long as you mix the
right trees of course and I wouldn't
like the fence to continue over here so
let's just do that nice and some benches
because I like benches and for some
reason I feel like that should be a
hedge around the food court kind of want
to make the food court stand out in a
sense and oh [ __ ] I've made a grave
mistake
never ever assign a handyman without
saying that he should not [ __ ] mow
cross stay there stop mowing the grass
okay thank you
now what do we need nothing really I
think this will be it for this episode
so how's the research doing at 20:50 lie
20 oh man that's still going to take
quite a while but yeah that's all gonna
be in the next episode so see you then
bye